[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
North America has always played second
fiddle to Europe in counterstrike look
back at the overpass game and it's just
two game a thing you know what we should
and could of won this tournament no
matter how good and in a team got it
always seemed like there was a ceiling
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a couple of teams proved that they could
hang with the best in the world but none
of them could be the best and those
glimpses of greatness were for years
just that but then came Team Liquid a
cast of characters molded through
trial-and-error helmet by a man who'd
been there through it all
where's the rest of the [ __ ] of they're
not gonna be there time nitro with the
massive break at a loss what to and
shuts down the entire French lineup
there is no question that na has finally
produced the best counter strike team in
the world the chorus territory
macMaster's champions 2nd in the intel
grand slam liquid champions where it all
began
here's the goat it 3 is on for North
America it just took them years to put
the puzzle together they say
everything's bigger in Texas they three
take us to be exactly 2015 Team Liquid
decided to get it on the counter-strike
craze and signed the former denial
esports roster so that is the big
announcement my teammates are gonna be
so the new Team Liquid csgo team is
gonna be myself adapts math fugly and
nitro like many of their na peer if they
performed well on their home turf but
failed to make any noise internationally
nitro one of us is three it's match
point here friend IP and Ally's gonna do
it with p90 n IP 16 to 1 what a crazy
crazy score line and well the series
from start to finish was a dominant
showing from the speeds while nitro was
liquids rising star his career up to
that point was pretty shaky and a lost
opportunity to play with IV power in
2014 almost caused him to quit csgo
altogether so yeah there was there's
some shirts here for sure you know I
didn't know how the game was gonna
develop obviously no one there really
and I got cut from iBUYPOWER and I was
like my ticket into the scene and
luckily like I joined the Nile afterward
they made a spot for me and came Team
Liquid so I'm still here today knife
through spent twenty fifteen entry
fragging but an unmotivated and
distracted nap needed to go and while
liquid would bring him back eventually
right then and there they replaced him
with the red hot illusion another part
of their eventual championship puzzle
Elysian the bombsite picks up the bomb
and takes out a dren he was at low HP
might not be ready for Miss Molly and
this nade is gonna combine no he's not
what a miracle place surrounded by fire
and 8g grenades people to pull it out
now is desperately needed round
teamliquid started 2016 with a bang they
signed simple one of the best players in
the world who seemed unstoppable with an
off in his hand Team Liquid were hoping
that he could make the difference they
were looking for
JDM nade out in behind the back of the
site not to be spotted though or not to
be taking any damage it is still simple
though he's rotated over he's now coming
to life and it's gonna be a dread that
pops out late in the short term it
worked Team Liquid became the first
North American team in cs:go history to
make it to the finals of a major at ESL
one cologne couple smokes in the same
place
but in the long-term it failed simple
left the active roster in April and left
for Navi entirely in August liquids
international gamble didn't pay off and
they were once again left with a roster
from na kehna strikes misfits E but
nitro continued to quietly improve he
tried his hand at Igla and though it
didn't work out he didn't tuck the
experience into his back pocket for
later something like that I've been
struggling with previous years what the
game leading was like I can't grow I
can't gather my thoughts fast enough to
like micromanage people mid round and
like that was my biggest issue like
bringing leading at that moment and back
then obviously I had a micromanage a lot
more than I have to today and then 2017
liquid signed their next championship
piece twists while charting out what
their long-term future was gonna look
like mom's does collect now that'll slow
the plant down Oscar oh he's not gonna
get there in time to deny everybody
knows Alicia's in the corner fantastic
control on the p2000 as twist tries to
do everything to defend the ball two
kills for him knows that he can pull off
Scarface he's got that twist he's gonna
try he turns it back with more liquid
steel crystal it was also a year of
professional growth for nitro who once
again took up the mantle of igl after
Stanislaw decided he didn't want to even
though that was the role he was signed
to play 2017 like midway through 2017 he
took over a leading role from San Jose
law and yeah I feel like he was so ready
to do it because he's played with a
decent Melvin game leaders in the past
and I felt like he finally understood
that he had the right mind to like lead
like a team and that just shows like a
lot of confidence that himself to you
that he's like prepared to take on this
rule and like lead a bunch of young
players and early 2018 liquid stumbles
at the Boston major but things weren't
all bad they also brought back Nath who
had spent the last three years growing
as both a person and as a player he's
gonna find the kit he's not gonna get a
10 second effusion oh there it is nitro
Wow way to finish things off and liquids
are your CS summit two champions
beginning in May liquid
International again and brought an MIB
ours taco to replace steel joining
fellow Brazilian Zeus who's been
recruited as their coach at the end of
2016 and they improved dramatically
during that period of stability making
it to the finals of six of the biggest
tournament in 2018 placing second each
time but five of those losses were to a
straw las' who naturally became Team
Liquid biggest rivals so incredibly
consistent the shot as strong as driving
home after what could have been a
disastrous comeback from Team Liquid
they seemed out of it but they have
shown that they had caught up to this
grand finals ready to fight by using a
strap heavy style similar to a straw us
liquid was able to beat every other team
in the world but they couldn't quite be
the original some people even took to
calling the minion strong I think
there's a little bit truth to saying
where the mini straws I think we stole a
lot from them for example like just
certain strats certain way sees our
utility and just stuff like that but in
terms of how they approach the game I
don't think we were necessarily like
that close to them I think they were
more strategic we're more like
individual little skill based trading
Nitra was finally coming into his own as
both an eye GL and an offer a role he
took up after JD Emma left and by
picking up the off he allowed his other
teammates to play to their strengths so
intriguing I don't know a lot of people
know like the mountain jizz like nitro
has gone through but he's like a very
confident offer now like he can like
stand up there like up against like
device and simple and like outplay them
not because like he's Michalka good but
he just smart at the end of 2018 Team
Liquid made a series of decisions that
would prove to be a turning point for
both the organization and nitro and it's
19 hp triple off a case womp excuse me 4
JW he does pick up the body from Russell
but now it's gonna be Stewart has to get
aggressive good final the first my best
chance for liquid and it's a one on one
smoke
perfectly Audrina returned to liquid
this time as coach with a ton of
strategic knowledge they also brought on
superstar Stewie 2k who they got in a
trade with MIB R for taco in the suits
so there's nitro going and it's on
Stewie they have to get coach to that
age oh you gotta be kidding me taking
down both players point-blank range
nitro Elysian aft whist and Stewie have
absolutely dominated 2019 combining the
strat heavy style of a straw with with
the wild frag heavy individual play that
na is known for we have like strong
fundamentals as players individually and
that just scoot it's all cohesive like
we all know what to do we can all do
every rule and I think that's what
separates us from like the old us and it
was a shot at the Intel grand slam on
the horizon it seemed like liquid was
finally getting into their group liquid
or victorious they have defeated the
Kings Astralis liquid are your iBUYPOWER
Masters champions
[Applause]
phenomenal phenomenal went from them
very deserving very hard-working team
and it's great to see that 2019 is gonna
be a great year for them it's a new dawn
but it kind of eats a liquid stumble
they failed to make it out of groups and
blew their shot to get a win on the
board for the Grand Slam at the time it
was an embarrassing loss and this was a
team that nobody thought anything of and
they'd just be one of the best teams in
the world but in true championship
fashion liquid and regrouped and brought
their best game I am he's got the seats
and he's gone it's all on the JW smoke
toy
[Applause]
this time there was no stopping nitro in
a surging teamliquid
Sydney gave them their first win on
their path to the Grand Slam then came a
win at Dreamhack Dallas and with it the
title of HL TV's best team in the world
thanks at least in part to Astralis
deciding to take a break and he detects
threat now he can sense players on the
other side if they kill but where
shortly he gets the first is this where
it ends a low and a three versus one
she's not tagged but he's got the kill
and like would have it they've got the
championship they've got masters and to
win the intel grand slam it's it's hard
to explain what the feeling like you get
but that's he had a number one ranking
with something special for us with two
tournaments down liquid entered the pro
league finals with a singular focus hit
against longtime nemesis a straw a
stopping face and dismantling mouse
boards finally it's g2 that we're in the
guillotine and the call is made the
Masters of both Sydney and Dallas its
liquid that had all the cards when their
opponents were trying to play checkers
liquid are the pro league season nine
champions and they carried that focus
over to ESL one cologne where they
capped off their Grand Slam run with a
win in the Cathedral of counter-strike
and one of the most important
tournaments of the year if it's off BK
this trough they come in serious trouble
they're taking
the favorites coming
look
haha
for tournament victories and sixty days
to put that into perspective
it took a straw love 323 days and nine
tournaments to complete the Grand Slam
when you're on the stage you look up and
you see that many people you're just you
have no words like you can't really your
speech this or no sense like because you
never really dreamed that being there
playing a video game really like that's
like everyone's dream is someone cologne
and winning cologne and winning the
Grand Slam there was like prior that
much a special moment mit has career
actually and then withdrawal was decided
to step back and attend the less
tournaments during liquids run you can't
take the accomplishment away from them
they've not only learned how to play
counter-strike on their own terms
they've learned how to win in the
process through trial and error and
experimentation nitro and Team Liquid
have solved the puzzle that is any
counter-strike
that's where focusing right now we're
trying to create our legacy and just
create history and stuff like that so
we're trying out the focus like honors
on the current the president right now
or just trying to focus on the the
future and maintaining the spot because
that's the hardest part right now thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up art Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages